brings me to a topic i'm very passionate
about which is birth control options
that are available to women i can't i
can't believe that we don't have better
options for birth control they all drive
me crazy what are you on
what are you taking
you have an iud come up here we're going
to take it out
i hate this product is yours plastic or
metal
yours is plastic okay well she's got a
mcdonald's toy in her body right now
most of them are metal some are plastic
most of them are a little piece of metal
they put inside your uterus i'm like i
don't want metal inside my body i don't
want to be
going through airport security
and having the guys behind the x-ray
machine like oh look at this slut coming
through
this bitch had to put a tin can up in
there
to stop all that sperm
no i don't want metal in my body what if
there's a storm
guys i can't make it tonight it's
raining
i hate this product mostly because like
they would never develop that product
for men that would never be a product on
the market for men right you and i would
never be dating and you'd be like babe
what should we do for birth control i'd
be like
i have an idea
how about we take a metal rod
and put it up your dick hole
and leave it there for about five years
or until it gets infected is that a good
idea
[Music]
i hate this product
and it has like three pages of side
effects i can't believe that they
release a product with three pages of
side effects i'm like go back it's not
ready
i looked at the side effects for the iud
it was like uh migraines abdominal pain
and depression i was like i might as
well have a fucking kid
[Applause]
what about you what are you up to
the pill do you know which one
no
this fucking generation man they don't
even they'll just put anything in their
mouths they don't even care
let go poison fine you don't even do you
know what color the box is at least
it's pink motherfuckers
i hate that that drives me nuts like
that is so everything about the pill is
insulting to me the fact they make the
box pink the pill is pink as if all
women just like love pink and if the
pill being pink affects your decision of
whether you're going to take it or not
that means you're 10 years old and
you're too young to be on birth control
anyway
okay
second of all if you want me to remember
to take my pill every day don't make it
pink make it in the shape of tiny crying
babies
i can't stand the pill i actually just
read this article about how the pill
works basically the way the pill works
is it tricks your body into thinking
you're pregnant your brain starts
producing the same neurochemicals and
hormones as if your body is pregnant you
know this you watch oprah good girl
and then you start being attracted to
more alpha males their pheromones start
smelling stronger and you're attracted
to alpha males the kind of man that
could protect your future offspring the
problem is that in modern times alpha
males are signified by tattoos and
motorcycles which explains why i've been
dating such assholes since i'm 15 years
old
the way that it works is that i meet a
nice sensitive guy i want to share my
future with i start taking birth control
to plan it and then all of a sudden i
only can have an orgasm if i smell axe
body spray that's not fair
and it's an example of how biology has
not yet caught up with modern technology
i it's the 21st century i don't need an
alpha male to protect me we have street
lights okay we have alarm systems i
don't need an alpha male i need a guy
with fast wi-fi so i can google can i
take xanax while pregnant that's my
baby's father